what's really funny is it's my someone
you met when we saw each other at a
Premiere thing and it was at the
premiere for Mando uh no it was this uh
the the Skywalker Premiere I forget what
it was but okay off camera listen I want
to start with uh we're talking about how
fabulous this shirt is and there's a lot
of context to how great the Remo
Williams shirt is he was surprised that
I knew what Rhema Williams was and I
almost hit him that's actually true you
have a a thing about violence and
reporters it's definitely been noted and
I appreciate not hitting me today you're
so welcome I think I'll restrain myself
for you
um listen I want that to get out there
that I beat up reporters
I'm obviously I was gonna curse but um I
want to start with I'm very happy with
how well things are going for you and I
just want to say as a fan of your work
it's great to see thank you so much and
as a fan of your nails I would like you
to show them to me please oh come on
please yeah but I only have like four
minutes all right all right I'm not
trying to be me you know um but I you
know uh so I wanna listen like I have to
because I'm such a I've seen all of Last
of Us yes including the finale people
are gonna love it um I just have to ask
you real quick about that um do you
think there's a chance you'll be filming
the second season this year in the year
2023 oh what season are we in now what
what's what it's we're getting into
spring yes there is a chance yes
um awesome moving into Mandalorian yes
um so one of the things about this is
that I'm curious how the recording
process works because you have eight
episodes this season are you actually
recording all eight episodes in one day
God no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no
no so how can you explain how a little
bit how it works oh it's a very extended
process uh in in post and there's so
many different ways to dip back in and
finesse look at the episode again
um it changed some of the writing
there's no lips that we're matching uh
and so from the beginning uh in season
one
even scenes that um there is absolutely
zero sound issue with me in the suit and
and playing the scene there's still
opportunity to go in there and and
fine-tune and make it as good as as what
everybody gets to experience when it
when it when it releases do you enjoy
recording the efforts or do you dread
those days
the efforts
um are very important and uh pretty
hilarious
uh it would be great to be able to see
that
um they always happen very very
generously towards the end of a
recording session so that none of the
really important stuff is compromised by
an exhausted Voice or body well I've
spoken to a lot of people that do uh
voice over stuff and they talk about how
the efforts can just wreck you yeah by
the end of the day because the only way
to make them really sound real is for it
to be real and so you are
it's it's very physical I can't wait to
see season three and I'm curious um how
would you compare uh season three to the
first two seasons it's a good question
without giving anything away I would say
that the surprises are not necessarily
what you would expect
um from uh uh uh our uh experience with
surprises previous to this season
um there's a kind of approach to the way
the story is told that is sort of
unexpected and
um and and I I love that
I know it's all very vague but it's
surprising what the surprises are
surprise
surprise my saliva is traveling through
the light
um towards the camera as I say surprise
on that note I need to go I'm just gonna
say sir it's a pleasure and I'm really
happy for him thank you